[Music]
of course meanwhile Ryan Reynolds shot
down a report that his marriage with
Blake Lively is in trouble in the shell
Turner joined the couple in New York now
Michelle from your perspective what did
you see well I saw a good-looking
married couple out enjoying each other's
company Cameron that's what I thought
now look this report claim that Ryan and
Blake are struggling to spend quality
time together
well not last night and they made it a
family affair
[Music]
Ryan was being next to white Blake and
his mom Tammy as they supported friends
John Krasinski and Emily Blunt at the
premiere for their movie a quiet place
you've got the Reynolds here tonight
Stanley are coming as well Stanley is
her Devil Wears Prada co-star Stanley
Tucci married to Emily's sister Felicity
Blunt
who is pregnant with their second child
protective this film is actually Emily
and John's first together in their
nearly 8 years of marriage I've
obviously been the biggest fan of hers
forever but to see her onset do what she
does it's a whole different thing
allowing that new site that we saw in
each other was really bonding yeah very
cool speaking of bonding at the after
party it was guys night out as Jennifer
Aniston's ex Justin Theroux showed up
solo and posed with Stanley and John at
home Krasinski's outnumbered with two
daughters but Emily says he still may
have the upper ring they might may like
John even more than a witch's slightly
upsetting at times when I asked a little
one like who's your best friend she said
I mean I'm still kind of top dog but
it's got to keep him working so it's not
there
[Music]